3° à 7
7° à 3 45 degrés à pontarlier et à
marseille 11° 5 à bordeaux et en
bourgogne 90° à angle droit
100 degrés à court bouillon 38,5 au lit
avec un grog et 0° dans la galerie des
glaces
une masse d'air chaud venant du pôle
nord et se déplaçant incognito vers nos
régions est conservera sur toute
l'étendue du territoire ce temps beau et
ensoleillé que nous connaissons depuis
trois mois donc soleil toute la journée
et même une partie de la nuit
sécheresse persistante favorisant les
pique niques ou les parties de campagne
prévisions pour le bronzage quelques
risques d'oxydation
oui évidemment vous rendiez bien compte
que depuis quelques instants il se
passait une série de choses insolites un
peu inhabituel pas très ordinaire et que
tout ça devait se terminer par une
incongruité cette incongruité
c'est ma présence ici devant les caméras
des actualités télévisées on ne comprend
pas très bien d'ailleurs pourquoi on m'a
demandé à moi spécialement de venir vous
présenter ses actualités aujourd'hui
peut-être parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est le
lendemain du 31 mars ou peut-être parce
que c'est la veille du 2 avril
car nous sommes aujourd'hui le 1er avril
ça c'est certain j'ai une grande
confiance dans le calendrier m'a envoyé
il est formel il est coin comme un petit
coin jeu est arrêté avec votre en 37
déjà c'est de la faire enfin toute chose
d'utile je suis là maintenant et vous
présenter non pas les actualités
télévisées comme vous avez l'habitude de
les voir mais les actualités télévisées
dont le premier sujet d'ailleurs
intéresse tout premier chef les
parisiens bien sûr et tous les français
qui en général ou en civil consomme de
l'essence
il y à du pétrole à l'étoile oui la
chose paraît à peine croyable on creuse
en plein paris en pleine place de
l'étoile
on creuse pour trouver du pétrole jour
et nuit des pionniers travail des
machines fort des moteurs tournent pour
arracher au sol de la capitale le
précieux pétrole source d'énergie et de
richesses déjà les tubes sont en place
dans la terre remuée
et bientôt les derricks se dresseront
dans le ciel de paris plaçant notre
ville parmi les principaux producteurs
de carburants au même titre que le texas
l'arabie et le sahara avec en moins bien
sûr le problème du transport
déjà une société s'est constituée la
ratp régie autonome des travaux
pétroliers les plans et les cartes sont
formels le pétrole est là dans l'oeil de
la capitale atteindre at on bientôt la
nappe pétrolifères c'est ce que nous dit
le sous chef depuis monsieur batterie
peau qui dirige le forage oui nous
espérons atteindre bientôt la poche de
gaz puis la nappe de pétrole propre
conduite
comment elle le sol de la place de
l'étoile à mouiller très mouillé avec
les pluies que nous avons eues ces temps
ci et le sous-sol poche nous avons
traversé plusieurs couches d'abord le
goudron du trottoir
c'est le plus dur puis du calcaire puis
de la marne qui se mélange avec les eaux
de la seine pour faire une couche que
nous appelons seine-et-marne
ça ne facilite pas le travail et vous
espérez vraiment trouver du pétrole
y'a pas de raison il ya déjà une aphonie
126,6 forte terme qui est déjà en
exploitation
les pompes qui sont là puissent
directement dans le sous sol pour
alimenter les voitures et nos ingénieurs
sont certain d'y arriver ici sans
difficulté votre nom
on sera peut-être obligé de déplacer un
peu l'arc de triomphe où il ya problème
mais dites moi monsieur 20 dépôts si
vous ne trouvez pas de pétrole lourd
bousserez tout ça oh non sûrement pas on
laissera tout comme sait et on en fera
une station de métro
voilà tout allez hop ragga et l'ens
paris centre pétrolier
voilà le vrai triomphe la vraie preuve
du redressement et de la richesse de la
france
remarquez si on veut amener quelque
chose de nouveau dans les actualités
télévisées ne suffit pas de changer le
générique qui ne suffit pas de présenter
des sujets intéressants mais un solide
comme celui que vous venez de voir il
faut aussi changer un peu le ton on se
parle il faut qu'on sente que le
journaliste se sent à l'aise qui ce sens
devant la caméra comme chez lui il n'est
ce pas comme s'il était avec des amis
devant des amis on ne se on ne se gêne
pas en main or ont un moment là on
mutile plein de situations de renac qui
se produit et on est amené tout
naturellement à parler littérature et à
part les prix littéraires
en me réveillant de la saison littéraire
on a décerné dans un grand restaurant
parisien le prix lautréamont va votants
18 abstentions une voix contre une voix
pour
mais c'était celle du président qui
comptent pour 10 c'est donc par 10 voix
contre une que le prix lautréamont et
décerné armand lanoux que nous avons
surpris au saut du lit
armand lanoux hormonal ou vous est ce
qu'on peut appeler un auteur heureux
puisque déjà lauréat du prix populiste
en 1948 je crois c'est ça
48 et surtout lauréat du prix goncourt
1963 vous venez d'obtenir décidément
c'est un déluge venait d'obtenir le prix
lautréamont 1964 qui étude des premières
récompenses
quand je pense que c'est même le plus
important de tous surtout que maintenant
vous l'avez bien sûr dit rarement là
nous je crois que l'oeuvre que vous avez
présenté qui a obtenu le prix de
lautréamont est totalement différente du
reste votre création
ah oui ça n'a vraiment aucun cas ça n'a
vraiment aucun rapport avec tes petits
volumes que j'ai publiés antérieurement
non c'est vraiment quelque chose voulu
faire quelque chose d'important quelque
chose non qui arrivait à englober toute
une partie de la population dans une
oeuvre romanesque que je suis contre la
disparition du personnage bon je suis
partisan des personnages et dans mes
romans antérieurs à mon avis il n'y
avait pas cette personnage lorsqu'il m'a
préoccupé avant tout c'était de faire
vivre un très grand nombre de
personnages à un nombre immense de
personnages et c'est pour ça que vous
aviez choisi le peuple devient le peuple
de paris tout entier le peuple de paris
c'était vie que je voulais mettre en
scène et alors j'ai été amené à
travailler d'une façon assez
scientifique parce que parce que tout
mais remonte ont un substrat historique
politique et économique de sérieux aussi
quel a été votre méthode de travail
bah j'ai établi des fiches c'était la
première chose à faire c'est un travail
essentiellement scientifique que le
travail du romancier avait toute une
nomenclature
alors j'ai fait une fiche pour chaque
programme et vous avez
collationner combien de ficheux
approximativement aux 481 5723 et comme
vous êtes trouvé en face de vos 485 1723
personnage qui est devenu l'action est
bien l'action d'elle même avait disparu
n'est ce pas la seule présence de ses
485 1723 personnage mises ensemble
vous pensez bien les petites histoires
et des vies de pêche ça devait des
petits de soi ces petites choses tout
était simple à ce moment là mes
personnages je n'avais plus kate qui a
publié ces fiches c'est ce que j'ai fais
d'ailleurs voilà le voilà le le premier
tome qui a eu le dessus et moi c'est
juste le premier tome se voyait moins le
voilà le le prix lautréamont henry alors
voilà le voilà le deuxième tome qui
était encore plus volumineux que le
premier il fait 300 pages le plus je
crois que nec voilà alors c'est très
simple vous trouvez vous voyez voilà je
ne sais pas si vous voyez très bien aimé
mais on nous allez vous rendre compte de
la quantité du travail et surtout de
l'invention romanesque que ça représente
de la quantité de l'imagination et bien
avant les lourds
nous pouvons tout d'abord que vous
féliciter pour ce prix lautréamont bien
méritée car voilà un livre qui ne
manquent pas d'adressent et vous
souhaiter un très fort tirage à combien
inspirez vous tirez vous savez on a
toujours dit toujours des petites
déceptions il ya des défections les gens
sur lesquels on compte et on a tort de
compter sur eux on va en gros aux 485
1723 à peu près le nombre de personnages
que vous avez marre seulement chacun se
sentant concernés bravo armand lanoux
vous avez fait là en oeuvre d'hommes de
lettres
je rappelle le titre des deux volumes
adler officielle des abonnés au
téléphone par armand lanoux prix
lautréamont 1964
eh bien oui c'était hier soir mardi 31
mars qu'a eu lieu comme chaque année le
bal annuel des scaphandriers par 15
mètres de fond dans le bassin numéro 4
du port de dunkerque
amal casque et bien entendu d'ailleurs
le scaphandre de soirée étaient drieu à
minuit c'était le concours de la plus
belle bulle et à lâcher de poissons
rouges
cotillons imperméable et confettis en
plomb rien ne manquait le gros lot de la
tombola un panier de vase de soissons a
été tiré au sort au profit de la caisse
aux pneumatiques de secours des
scaphandriers et de l'association des
fils de sous l'eau bel exemple de
solidarité qui devrait se généraliser
également sur la tête
art si tous les hommes grenouilles vous
laisse donner la palme
on a oui va continuer sans moi mes
enfants oui je vous dis c'est le
jourdain entièrement relaxer les
actualités reposante une fois pour
toutes
d'ailleurs vous savez les dépêches oh
pas de quoi inintéressant absolument
sans intérêt également celle là oui tout
cela
non même pas dont elle allait rouler
qu'est ce que ça peut faire que diable
c'est le printemps on est oui le
calendrier est formel c'est le printemps
depuis le 20 du mois dernier mais les
bourgeons ignore le calendrier et les
arbres ne savent pas compter sur leur
marche
et pourtant c'est le printemps quand
même le sens de paris circulent plus
vite dans ses artères
il y a quelque chose dans l'air une
sorte de complicité entre les oiseaux et
les choses
un je-ne-sais-quoi qui vous incitent au
rêve plus qu'au travail un je ne sais
quoi
il vous fait voir la vie en en un peu
plus rose
regardez la muse l'inspiration peut être
dépensé nettement plus libertine nom et
l'air un peu plus tièdes un rien plus
légers comme un appel à la paresse non
vraiment on n'a pas envie de travailler
ou alors si on travaille si on travaille
c'est avec un rien de fantaisie
d'optimisme le même
voire même de charme
et de délicatesse oui j'ai vraiment un
an c'est le printemps
et pourtant malgré ce printemps malgré
le calendrier malgré la logique même il
se passe dans le petit village de mais
il est de pognes dans le vaucluse
quelque chose d'assez inhabituel mais
non vous ne rêvez pas c'est bien un
arbre de noël et c'est bien monsieur le
maire de mais il est de punk qui nous
explique son point de vue ah ben c'est
pas difficile suffisait d'y penser c'est
tout depuis longtemps devant ne parle de
l'étalement des grandes vacances et les
journaux sont plaît vous explique en
long et en large que ça va
décongestionner les routes que ça va
empêcher la cohésion des plages
bravo moi je dis bravo seule main à mon
avis ce qui est valable pour les grandes
vacances c'est aussi pour les fêtes de
noël
et pourquoi pas à noël aussi à de la
bousculade de la corrida cogestion alors
pour éviter tout ça est bien la solution
est simple l'état
le mas des fêtes de noël par département
et par informatique de a à h
en décembre de 10 à elle 1 janvier de m
accueille février deux aires a eu à
marche et devait à z en avril et
crevettes nord c'est pourquoi nous ici
amélie et de poigne on a décidé de
donner exemple vaucluse v avril un
arrêté du conseil municipal a fixé noël
au 3 avril
mais alors tout en le réveillant la
messe de minuit
et puis alors le lendemain les joujoux
d'acheminer et hop le tour est joué
croyez moi ici on est des précurseurs et
calmes plus tard on aura étalé les fêtes
de noël de décembre à avril et ben nous
on sera fier de savoir que ces musiques
et de poigne qui a donné l'exemple à la
phrase toute entière
et d'abord pourquoi toujours assis sur
une chaise devant un bureau un soulman
un peu alors allons bousculons les
principes brison des cadres allez
faisons de la télévision sur une grande
échelle
là on domine la situation on est à la
hauteur des événements et on peut
vraiment en toute connaissance de cause
passer la parole à frédéric pautz cher
pour sa chronique judiciaire avoue
frédéric peu de chair j'ai quitté le
palais de justice ce très tôt cet après
midi pour une raison très simple parce
que il y faisait horriblement chaud je
ne sais pas si c'est une question de
réglage de chaudière mais véritablement
la température était absolument
intenable au pureau reste vous savez la
jolie n'était pas extraordinaire le rôle
de la 17e et est assez chargé c'est vrai
mais c'était des petites affaires qui
concernaient des gens dont vraiment vous
ne connaissez certainement pas les dons
et par exemple un certain hugo victor
qui était poursuivi pour abus de
conscience trois ans ferme bon a nommé
chopin frédéric était accusé par ses
voisins de tapage du nocturne une durée
c'est pas très grave
en effet c'est pas très grave seulement
voilà c'est qu'on soupçonne le même
individu d'avoir en plus exécuter un
certain nombre de polonais alors ça une
enquête a été ordonnée ce qui est tout à
fait normal il ya eu ensuite une affaire
de vol oui à un russe un appelé rimski
korsakov
il est accusé d'un vol du bourdon il
plaide coupable jugement à vittel
cantonaux mais charles kooh doha celui
là son compte est bon on l'a condamné à
cinq ans avec sursis pour faux et usage
de faux
le plaignant qui s'étaient portées
parties civiles un certain monsieur
gates a reçu un franc de dommages
intérêts on s'apprêtait à ce mois là a
jugé un certain josé maria de heredia
pour vol de chair fort du charnier
natale mais comme je voulais dire il
faisait si chaud que j'ai quitté le
palais de justice et je dois dire que si
on ne règle pas mieux les chaudières
eh bien c'est fini je ne mettrai plus
les pieds au palais bonsoir
une innovation dans la circulation
parisienne ce couloir spécial sur les
quais réservées au transport en commun
une simple bande jaune patte sur le sol
beaucoup d'agents pour la faire
respecter
et voilà comment les autobus peuvent
filer sur leur propriété privée
laissant derrière eux les automobilistes
et leur vignette parisien cette portion
de paris ne vous appartient plus et ce
n'est pas fini on regorge d'idées à la
circulation
c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous explique un
éminent spécialiste évidemment le
peloton
évidemment le projet de cet avis
évidemment le plongé de 7 personnes
évidemment le projet de cette fille
réservée exclusivement aux autobus
c'est déjà génial d'autant que l'été
n'étant pas large
une file au moins ça simplifie déjà les
choses et je dois reconnaître que nous
pouvons faire mieux
vous me direz ces autobus fait les
passer sur le trottoir et l'a déjà
évidemment honig n'espère 60 personnes
dans l'autobus puisqu'une trentaine en
dessous écrabouillé sans bavure ça
simplifie encore plus les choses mais je
dois dire que depuis ce matin le comité
a trouvé la vraie solution et ça je dois
reconnaître c'est la trouvaille du
siècle c'est le coup de génie
comment faire passer une fille d'autobus
avec file réservée sur la sauce et sans
gêner la circulation sur ceux ci
non impossible et je vous donne la
solution sous l'associer en dessous et
le tour est joué
suivez moi on creuserait sous terre des
grands tunnels dans lesquelles les
autobus circulerait à très vive allure
comme sur des rails sans souci d
encombrement et d'ailleurs pourquoi ne
pas mettre des lignes
ce sera encore plus rapide et dans ces
conditions on pourrait accrocher
plusieurs autobus ensemble 4 5 vous
rendez compte de ce qu'on pourrait
transporter et comme l'essence est chère
rien ne nous empêcherait de les faire
marcher à l'électricité puisqu'on a des
rails avec environ tous les kilomètres
un arrêt des escaliers pour remonter à
la surface et des couloirs de
correspondance sur terre
pour rejoindre d'une ligne à l'autre
s'assurait que ces révolutionnaires et
que nous en verrons au comité on a même
cherché un nom spéciale pour ces autobus
souterrain rapide sur rails nous avons
chassé chemin de fer urbain mais moi
urbain ça me chiffonne parce que j'ai
peur que ça vexe les banlieusards c'est
pourquoi j'ai passé à chemin de fer
metropolit est évidemment c'est un peu
plus l'homme et je connais les parisiens
ils ont vite fait de trouver une
abréviation tout ça pour vous dire que
question idées neuves
on travaille à la préfecture b oui il ya
une chose qu'on a tendance souvent à
reprocher à nos excellents confrères des
actualités télévisées c'est de consulter
trop souvent leurs notes sur leur table
seulement c'est bien excusables c'est
bien compréhensible on ne peut pas avoir
en tête toutes les nouvelles du monde
entier de la journée entière
alors ils sont obligés de regarder pour
se remettre en mémoire
on comprend très bien que pour le
téléspectateur c'est plus agréable
d'avoir quelqu'un qui vous regardent
dans les yeux alors je me permets de
signaler à l'attention de nos excellents
confrères et journalistes de télévision
ces lunettes de mon invention qui leur
permettront de regarder leur public dans
les yeux tout en consultant
tranquillement leurs notes comme ceux ci
donnant sied à l'ingénieur a trouvé le
moyen d'obtenir de l'essence avec de
l'eau son procédé consiste à prendre
dans sa cave des bouteilles d'eau
minérale qui y viennent sa grand-mère et
aller les vendre à l'épicier du coin
ensuite avec l'argent ainsi recueilli il
achète de l'essence alain stations
service
c'est aux dires des savants le seul
procédé actuellement connus pour obtenir
de l'essence avec de l'eau qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
on d'ailleurs maintenant quatre yeux
sont amplement suffisants pour aller
voir ce qui se passe sous la coupole
encore un nouvel immortel monsieur
christian plante un élu au fauteuil du
duc de saint jacut et cette élection a
une signification profonde elle montre
que l'académie française la vieille dame
du quai conti comme on l'appelle a
décidé d'élargir ses cadres en effet
monsieur christian plantain et catcheur
oui catcheur et c'est par le catch qu'il
est arrivé jusqu'à la coupole compte
déjà des militaires des poètes des
hauteurs de boulevard des
ecclésiastiques
un journaliste et un cinéaste
je suis fier qu un catcheur vienne
siéger parmi ses illustres personnalités
je suis fier que ce catcheur ce soit moi
d'ailleurs comme le dit son confrère
marcel achard qui a prononcé le discours
de réception
qu'on le veuille ou non le catch c'est
de la littérature
christian planta assistera-t-il aux
séances du dictionnaire non non parce
que je continue quand même mon ancien
métier
et quand le dictionnaire sera terminé
nous serons bien content de me trouver
pour le porter continué sous l'ancien
métier c'est le propre de tout
académiciens christian plantain passera
désormais de la coupole au ring sans
changer de tenue
internationale
au match aller
christian plantain de l'académie
française et de la salle wagram
combattra désormais sur deux fronts
dans un mois se déroulera la finale de
la coupe européenne de tire-au-flanc et
l'équipe de france s'entraîne avec
acharnement au stade jean bouin le
sélectionneur andré dagmar bûcher le
président de l'afa lé staff fédération
amateurs des ligues sportives de
tire-au-flanc de france qui surveille de
très près l'entraînement de ses poulains
le tire au flanc est un sport très
ancien qui demande à la fois de la force
et de la drees
vous en connaissez le principe il s'agit
d'envoyer dans une cible placée à 53 m
une part de plans de 114 grammes pour la
finale de la coupe européenne
j'ai sélectionné comme zen pipe et spire
oms qui à cause de leur détente
musculaire et de la précision de leurs
tirs à l'entraînement pour les amener
progressivement je les fais travailler
avec départ de flan de 108 grammes
seulement au lieu de 114 près les
enfants en âge mais au vu de tes la
marque ses sbires ont ski qui commence
il prend la part de flan dans la main
droite
la crème tourné vers l'extérieur la
croûte bien serré contre la paume de la
main
attention observer son style a raté
environ ce qui n'est pas au meilleur de
sa forme
dagmar bûche le réprimande
paternellement pareil tu t'es encore
saouler la gueule cordiaux biron ski
deuxième essai
le ralenti vous permet d'admirer
l'effort de l'athlète avant le jet est
réussi 2004 le dmp claudine pif plus
massif ne manque pas non plus d'une
grande précision
non non le tir est raté
assurez vous messieurs dames on tient
quand même la grande forme et à la coupe
d'europe de tire-au-flanc avait plein de
sunreef espérons ski l'honneur de la
france est en bonnes mains
ça va francs suisses 1 vous avez assez
jouer maintenant oui monsieur marcillac
major prends mes accessoires parce que
j'en ai besoin pour mon vrai journal
bien monsieur martin
et de deux